each year the academy allows the  producer of this show to pick one person  to present the next award this year our  producer joe pasternak gave us a choice  either the beautiful miss yvette minio  or producer joe pasternack  with absolutely no deliberation we chose  miss chevette mimeo  it is my honor to announce  the award for the best achievement in  sound effects the nominations are the  great race with sound effects by  trigowith brown and von ryan's express  with sound effects by walter rossi  the next sound effect you will hear will  be the opening of the envelope  the winner is to go with brown for the  great race  to the members of the academy  thank you very much to blake edwards and  rudy fair  who gave me the assignment  thanks a lot and the team that worked  with me  to help me win  the little boy  good night god bless you